[Music]
hands up if you have ever heard yourself
or friends saying I'm trying to lose
weight I'm cutting out cups we've been
brainwashed to believe that cups will
make you fat and that you should stay
away from it
well that's absolute rubbish because not
all cups are created equal
just take a look at this picture
everything here are cups if your diet is
filled mainly with low quality carbs
which has almost no nutrients then yes
you will overeat and gain weight however
high quality cups are packed with
nutrients and slow digesting adding
these cups into your diet can help to
speed up metabolism burn fat and also
help you to lose weight I like to call
them smart cups what are smart cups they
are extremely nutrient dense and they
are high in fiber they will help to
improve your digestion they will have to
stabilize blood sugar they will sustain
your energy level they will help you to
feel fuller for much longer they will
improve your physical performance and
they will not be highly refined let's
talk about eleven smart cups you should
be adding into your diet first sweet
potato do you know that the Okinawan
staple food is Papa's sweet potato the
residents in Okinawa Japan have some of
the longest lifespan in the entire world
eighty-five years for men and
eighty-seven point three years for women
and Okinawan reaching 100 years of age
has a BMI of twenty point four in their
early adulthood and also middle age
despite the name Hsu potato doesn't
actually belong to the potato family in
comparison to normal potato sweet
potatoes are less starchy and contain
less calories sweet potatoes are
superior when it comes to the vitamin A
content a cup of cooked sweet potato
contains three thousand times the amount
of vitamin A as a potato
it is also naturally sweet which means
you can add them into your diet without
any additional sweeteners
I love having sweet potatoes as my
pre or post-workout snack to give me the
energy boost and to satisfy my muscles
but that doesn't mean you should
completely avoid irregular potatoes
because they are still packed with
nutrients and fiber consume them in
moderation and they can be part of your
healthy diet are you doing everything
right but you can't seem to get a flat
belly no matter how hard you train or
how well you eat a bloated tummy can
make even the most toan stomach look a
bit pudgy bananas are very rich in
potassium a natural diuretic which will
reduce water retention and bloating
giving you a flatter belly bananas are
also rich in glucose a highly digestible
sugar which provides quick energy hence
it is always the number one snack choice
for endurance based activity such as
running a marathon just consuming two
bananas prior to your workout can help
you to sustain up to 90 minutes of
steady paced cardio the low GI and high
fiber also means carbs are slowly
released into your body avoiding sugar
crashes and spurring the muscle recovery
process so add a banana to improve your
workout performance and improve
digestive health
I love squash whether it's butternut
squash pumpkin or acorn squash I mean
here this 100 grams of baked squash has
only 37 calories and loaded with vitamin
A C and calcium I think food rich in
vitamin C can help enhancing your
workout performance and reduce fatigue
this also means that your body will
become more efficient in burning fats
and of course calcium is extremely
important for bone health squash is also
high in antioxidants which will help you
to maintain your youthful appearance
their delicious roasted added onto salad
or blended to make creamy soups or stew
they are perfect all year round and
because they are so low in calories but
packed with nutrients it is hard to
overeat and you should add them into
your diet so what's your favourite
squash let me know in the comments
below study morning with oats it is low
in GI and high in fiber a bowl of oats
for breakfast can last you to lunch
without feeling peckish majority of the
fiber in oats a soluble fiber just think
of it like a sponge it absorbs water
expense in the stomach
hence keeping you fuller for longer
eating low GI cups causes a steady rise
in your blood sugar which will be used
for immediate energy rather than being
stored as body fats choose pure rolled
oats and add your own toppings such as
nuts and seeds fruits or cinnamon powder
avoid those instant oatmeal which tend
to have flavoring and also sweeteners
beetroot is a non starchy high cup of
vegetable a half cup portion of sliced
beets has eight point five grams of
total cups which consists of 1.7 gram of
dietary fiber and 6.8 grams of sugar the
natural sweetness in beetroot makes it
the ideal weight loss food simply add it
into baked goods make juices or top it
onto salad to enhance the flavour of
your dishes I'm sure some of you might
have come across the trend of drinking
big juice prior to a prolong workout
well that's actually an explanation
behind that beetroot is high in
inorganic nitrous which is known to
enhance physical performance during
endurance exercises it makes the muscles
more fuel efficient thereby enhancing
stamina one study has shown that just by
drinking half a litre of beet juice
every day can enable cyclists to cycle
16% longer without feeling exhausted so
this trend is worth following quinoa I'm
sure you must have heard of this super
green vine now it is incredibly popular
because it contains all 9 essential
amino acids which our body needs to
build and maintain lean muscles the more
lean muscles you have the more calories
you burn which means quicker weight loss
every cup of cooked quinoa contains 8
grams of protein and 5 grams of fiber
with no saturated fats it
also gluten-free so reduce on your meat
consumption and start adding quinoa into
your diet you can have it for breakfast
or even lunch just like quinoa buckwheat
is gluten free and it's a complete
source of protein despite its name
buckwheat is not related to read and it
is not a grain the edible portion is a
seed from a plant related to greens like
rhubarb instead of consuming pasta try
replacing with buckwheat noodles also
known as soba noodles traditional pasta
is made from refined flour which tends
to be higher in calories cups and sugar
on the other hand soba noodles have less
calories high in fiber and protein each
cup of cooked soba noodles contain about
113 calories whereas spaghetti contains
220 calories and the whole-wheat version
contains 174 calories just by applying
this simple swap you will reduce your
calorie intake and you will lose weight
next barley growing up I remember
drinking barley water almost on a daily
basis whenever we don't feel too well
we're always told to consume barley
what is it about barley that makes this
a Smartcar this underrated grain is one
of the world's oldest super foods
containing all the essential nutrients
it is also a killer appetite suppressant
that can help to reduce your cravings
because of the anti inflammation
properties eating barley will not make
you feel bloated but instead you will
feel lighter and satisfied you can
replace rice with barley you can make
stir-fry barley rice risotto barley soup
or stew or toss it onto salads
half a cup of cooked / barley contains
97 calories 22 grams of carbs and 3
grams of fiber pearl barley is the most
common barley but barley growths contain
even more nutrients you will be getting
20 to 25 percent of your daily fiber
needs in one serving number 9 on my list
is black beans beans are a great source
of protein which are packed with fiber
half a cup of boiled black beans
have 120 calories 20 2.5 grams of carbs
seven point five grams of protein and
eight grams of fiber they are also rich
in folate a big vitamin the Phils muscle
growth and copper which strengthens the
tendons they are rich in soluble fiber
which aid in reducing visceral fats the
fat that accumulates around the belly
area which can also lead to diabetes
heart disease and other illnesses so big
eaters have 23% lower risk of expanding
waist lines and 22% lower risk of being
obese beans are also a really cheap
source of protein making it an excellent
choice for plant-based eaters or also
meat eaters buy the low-sodium version
or rinse your beans to reduce the sodium
content before eating them amaranth this
super green has a lot of similarities to
quinoa it is high in fiber high in
protein and it's gluten free one cup of
cooked amaranth has 252 calories 46
grams of carbs 5 grams of dietary fiber
and 9 grams of protein compared to white
rice at 45 grams of cups only 1.2 grams
of dietary fiber and 4.2 grams of
protein so it is a much better option
compared to rice although MRF is a
planet native of Peru it is now grown
all across the world including countries
like China Russia Thailand Mexico and
even Nigeria in fact amaranth porridge
is a traditional breakfast in Nepal
India and even Peru you can even pop it
popped
Emer n can be added onto toast and even
into granola bars so if you haven't
heard of amaranth
give it a try and the final smart cup I
have to include is popcorn popcorn is a
whole grain which means it's a great
source of dietary fiber it is gluten
free sugar free and fat free air-popped
popcorn is a great low calorie snack to
include into your diet one cup of plain
air popped popcorn only has 31 calories
it has a lower calorie per unit volume
compared to other snacks which makes it
an ideal choice for weight loss you
well feel more satisfied when snacking
on popcorn in comparison to pretzels
potato chips on nachos which tend to be
high in saturated fats sugar and also
sweeteners but just be aware of flavored
popcorn as they will pack additional
sodium sugar and fat which can ruin your
diet I hope this video has convinced you
to add smart cups into your diet even if
you're on a low-carb diet your body
needs cups to be at its best state and
to speed up weight loss if you're
constantly feeling hungry you don't feel
satisfied even after a big meal or
perhaps you're feeling cranky low in
energy and you don't feel like your
workout is improving those are signs
that your body is lacking in carts
consumed smart carbs in moderation and
you will start to see the difference in
your physical appearance the way you
feel and you will achieve your results
quicker be sure to LIKE this video share
this information on and I've also added
a lot more video links in my description
box below to get you through your
fitness journey plus a lot of healthy
and delicious recipes if you haven't yet
subscribed to my youtube channel be sure
to do that okay hit the notification
button so that you won't get notified
every time I share a new video all the
best and eat your cards